This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world.
Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO. percent on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On the Look Back at it podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me.
I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people.
Listen to look back at it on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hard Way with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that doesn't. not mean that you need to.
Listen to learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. Owens, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg, a lesbian.
Michael Mancini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hello everybody and welcome back to the psychology of your 20s, the podcast where we talk through some of the big life changes and transitions of our 20s and what they mean is.
for our psychology. Hello everybody. Welcome back to the show. Welcome back to the podcast. New listeners, old listeners, wherever you are in the world. It is so great to have you back for another topic, another episode where we break down the psychology of our 20s. Okay, so you have read the title. You know what we're getting into today. And if you are a loyal listener of the show, you know that we are doing a very different episode to what we usually do. I very rarely talk about pop culture on this podcast, but I've come to realize that this person, this topic, feels timeless. And I have justified to myself that it is also relevant to our 20s, at least to mine. And when I suggested it over on my Instagram, you guys went wild. So you know what? Let's do it. And that topic is the psychology of Taylor Swift.
and the reason why so many of us across the globe, not just as individuals, but as an entire collective, have such a deep love and obsession with her as an artist. Taylor Swift is probably the most famous person in the world right now and has been a well-known celebrity for decades at this point, which is really difficult to do, especially as a female musician where there is this constant trend and cycle of momentary celebrity. and fame that comes in waves where, you know, the new best thing, the new shiny thing is picked up and dropped off very quickly. And yet, every year, it feels like she reaches incredible new heights, new fans, new milestones in career building moments. Her fame, I honestly think cannot be contained. And that is a bit of a superpower in the modern age of entertainment and celebrity culture. We have seen that especially this year with the Erez Tour,
which was possibly the hardest concert ever in history to get tickets to, and also may have saved the literal US economy, if you believe, some sources. It's mania. It's Swift mania. And the only way I think that we can really understand the impact that one person, Taylor Swift, has on people, is by really examining the psychology behind her, not just as a person, but as a celebrity, as a brand, and as a business. But also as someone who a lot of us, especially hardcore fans,
feel like they have a personal relationship with. They feel like they know her on some deep, social, mental level, despite never having met her. What is it about Taylor Swift that causes people to spend thousands of dollars to devote their lives to her, to know everything about her life. And as this relates to our 20s as well, I feel like for many of us, Taylor Swift and her music kind of provides us with somewhat of a guide and an emotional outlet for all of the universal experiences that we go through in this decade. Her songs are a voice to what we are experiencing even as non-celebrities, and that is her power, her ability. to make something relatable, like heartbreak, deeply personal and poetic.
It's also worth acknowledging that the majority of her fan base is between the ages of 20 to 30, right during this formative period. And I think that bears examining as to why her music is so powerful for people in this age bracket. People who have grown up with Taylor, who maybe started listening to her at 10, 11, 13, 14, when she released Speak Now or Fearless, and now are adults who see a lot of their experiences and their stories as they transition into this new period of their life reflected in her music. And, you know, in terms of my 20s, Taylor Swift and her albums have genuinely bookmarked certain chapters of my life and milestones that I think are very universal and incredibly important.
You know, I fell in love for the first time when her album, lover came out. We all went through lockdown and a global pandemic playing her two surprise albums, you know, folklore and evermore. I moved to a new city as Midnights was released. And the songs on those albums have been the soundtrack to my life for many, many years. Basically, I'm adding myself as a massive swiftly. I can give you all the reasons I wanted to do this episode, but mainly it was to examine my own psychology when it comes to my loyalty. and my love for her. I also think that if you are a loyal listener of the show, that will come as no surprise. I said to my friend the other day, I genuinely think about her at least five to ten times a day.
Ever since my dad bought me her first album when I was seven years old, she has been part of my life, little known secret as well. I even have a Taylor Swift tattoo, and I'm not embarrassed by that at all. So maybe when we talk about the psychological underpinnings behind our obsession with Taylor Swift, what I'm really doing is offering myself up as a case study. This is me breaking down my very own parasycial relationship with her, hoping that at least one person out there can relate. So in this episode, we are going to break down all the psychology behind why we find Taylor Swift so captivating.
We're going to explore the psychology of obsession of parasocial relationships and celebrity worship syndrome. the power of escapism and what certain music does to our brains and the pleasure centres in our minds, why it is that we have specific music preferences. We're going to focus on the underpinnings of relatability and fostering relatability through similarity and authenticity, the significance of storytelling. And we're also going to look at why certain decisions that Taylor Swift has made throughout her career have proven so successful because of how they have leveraged important aspects of our psychology. I'm talking about her use of errors, her use of Easter eggs, her use of so many
other parts of her brand that have made her fame become and seem genuinely unstoppable. There is so much to cover things that I didn't even imagine when first looking into this. I think it just goes to show how everything truly is psychology, including the celebrities that we love and music and fame all rolled into one. So if you can't tell, I'm so excited to get into this episode, so excited. So without further ado, let's examine the psychology behind everything we love and sometimes dislike about Taylor Swift. 2%. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter, and on my podcast, 2%, I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange
modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more, to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry. We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong. Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the result of stress. Put yourself through some hardships and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's T-W-O-Persent on the I-Hart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. There's two golden rules that any man should live by. Rule one, never mess with a country girl.
You play stupid games, you get stupid prizes. And Rule 2, never mess with her friends either. We always say that trust your girlfriends. I'm Anna Sinfield, and in this new season of the girlfriends... Oh my God, this is the same man. A group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist. I felt like I got hit by a truck. I thought, how could this happen to me?
The cops didn't seem to care. So they take matters into their own hands. said, oh, hell no. I vowed I will be his last target. He's going to get what he deserves. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe. On the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts,
or wherever you get your podcasts. Do you remember when Diana Ross double-tapped little Kim's boobs at the VMAs? Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people. I know what you're thinking. What the hell does George Bush got to do with Little Kim? Well, you can find out on the Look Back at it podcast.
I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex Inman. Each episode, we pick it here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill, waxing all about crack in the 80s. To be clear, 84's big to me, not just because of crack. I'm down to talk about crack on day, but just so y'all know. I mean, at this point, Mark, this is the second episode where we've discussed crack. So I'm starting to see that there's a through line.
We also have AIDS on the table right now. Thank you for finishing that sentence. Yes. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Really? Yeah. For me, it's one of the most important years for black people in American history. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts.
Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hard Way with me, your host, and your favorite therapist, Kear Games. And in recognition of mental health awareness month, I'm bringing over a decade of my own experience in the mental health field and conversations with so many incredible guests. I'm talking, Tripp Fontaine, Ryan Clark. Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing, we get so wrapped up in the chase that we don't realize that we are in possession of the thing. And we're still chasing it. And we don't know when we've done enough. Because people scoreboard watch.
Life becomes about wins and losses. Steve Burns, Dustin Ross, because you find it important to be a good person while you hear on earth. Or are you a good person because you're afraid? Because that's two different intentions, bro. Absolutely. And that's two different levels of trust. I want you to just really be a good person.
person. Join me, Keir Gaines, as we have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose on my new podcast, Learn the Hardway. Open your free Our Heart Radio app, search Learn the Hardway, and listen now. So Taylor Allison Swift was born famously on the 13th of December, 1989, a year that has since gone on to inspire her titular album named after the same year. A bit of background and biographical information for people who may not be diehard Swifties because this context is super important. Taylor was born in Pennsylvania and she was raised on a literal Christmas tree farm, which is pretty iconic if you ask me.
And this is really important. This origin story is important because Taylor, for her fans, has this really relatable small town, big dreams origin story, one which we all can't help but love because it makes us feel a very deep and appealing sense of possibility that we could also reach her levels of stardom and success coming from a non-famous background like she did but additionally it's a very sentimental story right that she really wanted to pursue music she moved to Nashville when she was like 14 she worked really hard she wrote all these beautiful autobiographical songs it makes us feel a special sense of protectiveness, but additionally, real familiarity with
this small country home, the small town vibe, that family feel it captures our attention. That's the thing about Taylor Swift that her biggest fans will tell you. Despite all of her success and fame, she has remained a very authentic and relatable person. She has this cozy feeling to her. She is best friends with her mom. She has these cats that she loves. It's this very small town girl next door feel for those of us who attach to her. Of course, nowadays, she is incredibly famous.
And that really started with the release of Fearless in 2008, Speak Now, Red, and then 1989, which really took her to new heights, not just as an artist, but as a celebrity. If you ask most fans, there is this before and after to Taylor Swift story, centering on the very infamous Taylor Swift is over party that happened back in 2016. And I think that that could have ended her career. You know, a cancellation of that magnitude from some pretty well-known celebrities. That is a huge deal. but instead she used this to transform herself into a new version of Taylor.
The one that I would say is possibly more likable because she wasn't perfect anymore. And we're going to talk more about her use of errors later on, but following this series of events that I think we all know about, she released reputation. And that is where we see this shift from her being this young pop star to being a mature adult musician. She began swearing on her song. She talked about alcohol and revenge and a lot more heavy emotions that she had previously
really steered away from. And I don't think that that was a deliberate marketing move, right? I think the thing unique to Taylor Swift is that she has grown up in the spotlight. We have seen her to traverse and survive her first decade of adulthood as a highly visible person. We have witnessed her development, not just as. as an individual, but as an artist. And we have seen how the themes of her music have matured and developed, and that is highly appealing to the everyday listener who is also going through those same transitions just at a different level, who gets to see their same messy, chaotic, deeply
feeling imperfect selves reflected in Taylor Swift's journey. It feels personally relatable. It feels personally relevant. I would say that some people would think that Taylor Swift has been defined by her drama, her scandals, the men that she has dated, but I don't think that is a very nuanced perspective and I think it's also deeply incorrect. Really, her success comes down to one thing and one thing only, and that is her ability to write songs that we all feel could very easily be about us. You and me, living out our everyday lives, the relatability behind her lyrics and music, it makes it feel like someone has put a voice to some of our own very universal feelings. And not in this really fantastical, glamorous way or manner, one that is imbued by fame, but in a way that is
super simple and digestible because it is so relatable. And it uses these really foundational tools of storytelling. It uses metaphor. It uses, you know, tropes and stories that we all know of Romeo and Juliet, of Julius Caesar, of unrequited love. That is really, really familiar to us. And she's also very well known for those verbal hooks as well. She has this impeccable ability to write bridges that are addictive and memorable, like in all too well. She says, you called me up again just to break me like a promise, so casually cruel. in the name of being honest. It rhymes.
It's poetic. It's succinct. In Cruel Summer. She has the bridge, you know, the very end of her bridge that's like, I love you. Isn't that the worst thing that you have ever heard? That is memorable. That is powerful. Our brains love something that is easy to remember, that is sharp, that is profound, that
gives us a message. But let's look at this highly relatable nature to her songs and the stories within. them. The thing that I think is really powerful is that a lot of celebrities, a lot of artists in particular, become famous and lose touch. But on Evermore, in Tis the Tem season, you know, Taylor Swift talks about what it's like to return back to your hometown for the holiday season and reunite with a high school lover. She sings about running away with a childhood friend in folklore or getting too drunk at the bar and needing to be taken home by your friends and hit different, regretting a breakup in back to December. And then, you know, there's the three songs
on folklore that are about a love triangle between two, you know, three people that takes place in locations that are ubiquitous as parking lots and shopping malls and in the back of a high school classroom. Those situations, those settings are highly, highly simplistic, relatable, universal, we can all see ourselves in those moments she's talking about, in those places that she's speaking about. And she was writing those songs at a time when she had a net worth of over $300 million. That fame, that success has not altered her very intuitive ability to take very commonplace human experiences and turn them into music and songs that we love. no matter what you're feeling, Taylor Swift has probably got a song that explains that exact moment,
meaning that her discography, it almost offers a dictionary of human emotion, whereby we can search up a feeling and return with a song that will capture exactly what we're experiencing, and it won't be dressed up in fancy clothing or make any reference to her status as a celebrity. She does not alienate people. in her songwriting. So psychology shows us that this relatability that Taylor Swift wields is one of the most powerful things that a celebrity can possess. And it comes down to these very simple principles of similarity and familiarity. There is this theory in social psychology known as the similarity attraction effect, which refers to the deeply ingrained tendency to like someone more when we
think that we are alike, or when we believe that we have shared similar experiences, this has been proven in a number of studies, including one in 2007, which measured the degree of likeness between friends and how each of the pair rated their mutual attraction to the other. So the more that they felt like their friend had been through similar struggles to them, had similar values, similar experiences, the more likely they were to want to be around them to express praise and love and admiration for their friend. So take that micro interpersonal example and apply it to the relationship between Taylor Swift and her fans. When she writes intimately about the pain of her first heartbreak, we listen to that and we see ourselves
reflected in those lyrics. When she talks about missing long-time friends, when she talks about not knowing the future of your relationship, of feeling scared to grow up, of feeling like a failure, we feel ourselves in that music. And so our brain, activating this similarity attraction nexus, likes her more. It also comes down to this idea of escapism and our use of music as a mental escape. So escapism is this idea that we use certain activities or forms of entertainment as a mental diversion or distraction from the unpleasant things in our daily life. So it kind of acts as a coping mechanism to protect us from uncomfortable feelings, situations, where we're perhaps not quite ready to face reality by directing our attention to something
that is more safe or enjoyable like particular songs or comfort artists. So researchers have shown that music serves as a really important tool in those moments. It eases our anxiety, it improves mood, it boosts our confidence, and it also decreases our sense of isolation, especially when the songs we are listening to mimic the emotional experience we are trying to navigate. Or more importantly, when the song, we are trying to navigate. or more importantly, when the song tells us a story that we can become invested in. So Taylor Swift writes those songs that tell those stories, that tell stories of revenge, of love, of heartbreak, of growing up.
And listening to these stories provides us with a vicarious sense of release, or what is known as emotional catharsis, because she has put into words the things we don't know how to. That is why we love her music so much. because it offers us a place to kind of hide away from the things that are bothering us by escaping into her life and her stories and her feelings rather than our own. It also comes down to the psychology behind our music preferences. What artists and songs and genres we like feel so deeply personal
and that's because it is. It is highly correlated to our personality and our self-concerted. We've seen studies that have shown that we select music based on how we see ourselves, based on our identity. And we know that identity is something that is self-directed, whereby we are actively choosing the person we want to be and what they look like. So they found in this study conducted in 2020 that based on an examination of over 80,000 people, we prefer music from artists whose personalities and identities we see ourselves in. So based on things like age, like gender, like race, interests, and the public personality of this person. So we have someone like Taylor Swift,
right, who is not only, as we've talked about, highly, highly relatable in her music, but she also has this very girl next door feel. We can easily look at her and identify the ways in which, you know, her and us are alike. We fantasize about how we could, you know, go and grab a drink or a coffee with her and chat for hours. And that also comes down to the fact that her songs are really autobiographical and personal. So we feel like we already know a lot about her because she shares so much about her life through her music. We could talk about her latest breakup, about how her mum's doing, what her friends are up to, her cats, whatever it is. Importantly, all of those things are things that are things that we would talk about to a good friend because it's all there in what she puts in her songs.
And so, you know, by logic, in a sense, she is our friend now. I also have a personal theory that this is really elevated by her use of Easter eggs in her music. So an Easter egg in pop culture is like a little hidden message that an artist puts in their songs or their music videos or their posts, outfits, anything. and it acts as a clue or some secret message that only their fans can interpret. So it also acts as almost like a scavenger hunt, right, that like indicates things that are in the works, when the next album is coming out, what they're going through in their life, upcoming announcements. And Taylor Swift uses Easter eggs, I think, like no one else.
She sometimes plots them, places them, months in advance only to suddenly reveal this huge thing like a tour, like a movie, like a surprise album that she has, when we look at it in hindsight, really been hinting at for a while. So when she reveals that kind of little game that she's been at, that Easter eggs, those Easter eggs she's been leaving, it kind of elevates and provides a sense of mystery and anticipation that has her fans watching her movements even closer looking for the next set of clues that she's currently leaving. So every single one of her listeners is now a detective. Now feels really intimately involved in finding ways to really deconstruct her everyday actions
with the bigger hope that they'll stumble upon some bigger hidden message that she's leaving them. It makes us more attentive. It makes for a more attentive fan base. But it also has the secondary a consequence of once again feeling like she is somehow in personal communication with us. Of course I think it goes without saying that this can cause its own problems when we forget that this person is ultimately, unfortunately, as much as we may want her to be, not our friend. We may feel really close to her due to her autobiographical relatable music, due to her public image, but she is basically a stranger. And this is where we get into the idea of parasocial relationships.
So in psychology, a parasycial relationship occurs whereby one person feels really deeply connected and invested in someone extends a lot of emotional energy, interest, time, money into this person. And the other party is completely unaware of their existence. So this is really regularly and most commonly, seen with celebrities whereby we think that we have this kind of reciprocal relationship with them due to repeated exposure and consumption of their music, their content, their interviews, but by nature it is entirely one-sided. And of course, Taylor Swift is a massive target for
these kinds of feelings, these kinds of quote-unquote relationships that we feel that we're having with celebrities. You know, I was looking at it the other day. She has like close to 300 million Instagram followers and 100 million monthly listeners on Spotify. It would be impossible for her to know or have even the slightest knowledge of every single one of those people, despite how loyal we may be, despite how much we might love her, defend her, support her. And the parosocial nature of this means she has incredible influence where we will replicate her behavior. We will copy her style by the drinks she likes. the clothes she wears, all of her music, but we have little reward coming from her as a person.
And the reason that we're able to foster this kind of relationship, this connection, is because she is a celebrity. She is a celebrity. There are constant news articles written about her, photos, gossip, interviews, red carpet appearances to the point that, especially nowadays, that she is more public than she was in recent years, we probably know more about her daily life than we do of our friends or our family members. And when we form that attachment, it's a really hard one to break.
It's actually called a parasocial breakup. And some studies have suggested that the emotional distress of feeling like we are becoming detached or removed from a celebrity that we love is just as intense as a real-life breakup or some kind of interpersonal conflict or separation. So I think this actually really explains something that happened around 2015, 16, where we saw so many diehard fans of hers become genuinely upset and confused and quite lost when she disappeared for almost two years before the release of reputation, when she made a conscious decision to shut off access to her personal life. There were no photos of her. There were no appearances. no social media posts.
And she says in her documentary, you know, no one physically saw her for a year. And that genuinely led to withdraw from the fans of hers who had come to see her as more than a celebrity. They came to see her as a friend. They felt betrayed, upset as if they were kind of owed some kind of explanation or insight.
Because of the nature of this one-sided relationship, we forget she's famous, we forget that she doesn't know us, but we also forget that she is just a person and having millions of people watching your every move, commenting constantly on your love life, everything you say online, every lyric, it would be really exhausting.
But it's no surprise that we're seeing more of these parasocial relationships the more popular social media becomes. And it can actually result in some really strange, really aggressive behaviours, you know, instances of stalking, not just with Taylor, but with many celebrities, you know, break-ins, obsessive monitoring. If you've ever watched the movie, I think it's called The Bodyguard with Whitney Houston and Kevin Crosstner or something like that, it's an old one, but it's a really fantastic depiction of what
但社交媒体越受欢迎，我们看到这种准社会交往的现象就越多，这也并不奇怪。这实际上会导致一些非常奇怪、极具攻击性的行为，比如跟踪行为——不仅仅是对泰勒，对很多名人也是如此——比如非法闯入、痴迷监视。如果你看过一部电影，我想叫《保镖》，由惠特尼·休斯顿和凯文·科斯特纳主演什么的，这是一部老电影了，但它非常精彩地刻画了
parosocial relationships can look like at the severe end of the spectrum. When it gets to the point of what we call celebrity worship syndrome. So basically that is a type of parosocial relationship that occurs when our admiration for a celebrity shifts into an obsessive fascination and preoccupation. It's been described as a literal obsessive addictive disorder whereby we are compulsively invested in this person's life beyond our control, meaning we know we should stop, but we don't know how to. We become so mentally intertwined with this person. They are such a core part of our identity that we genuinely don't know what we would do without them. And obviously this is really, really rare. But when you are at the level of stardom, that Taylor Swift is,
准社会交往在极端情况下会是什么样子。当它发展到我们所说的“名人崇拜综合症”的地步时。基本上，这就是一种准社会交往，发生在我们将对名人的崇拜转变为痴迷和全神贯注的时候。它被描述为一种字面意义上的强迫性成瘾障碍，即我们不受控制地沉迷于这个人的生活，这意味着我们知道自己应该停下来，但又不知道该如何停止。我们在精神上与这个人交织得如此之深。他们是我们身份的核心部分，以至于如果没有他们，我们真的不知道自己会怎么样。显然，这种情况非常非常罕见。但当你达到泰勒·斯威夫特那种明星地位时，
I would say there are probably at least a few people out there who have gotten to this point. Actually, I know that there has been. There was a man who was literally arrested in May of this year for stalking her and sleeping in her bed. which, you know, I would be moving out after that. If someone came into my house and slept in my bed, that is terrifying, regardless of how famous or how much money you make. So I think it's time for a bit of a break here to have a bit of a braver. So go and listen to Red Taylor's version or the album of your choosing.
我想可能至少有少数人已经达到了这种地步。事实上，我知道确实有。今年5月，确实有一个男人因为跟踪她并在她的床上睡觉而被捕。说实话，如果发生这种事，我早就搬走了。如果有人闯入我的家里睡在我的床上，那太可怕了，无论你多出名或赚多少钱。所以我觉得现在是时候休息一下，喘口气了。去听听《Red (Taylor's Version)》或者你选择的专辑吧。
Get yourself a cup of tea before we discuss the power of Taylor Swift's marketing, the impact of her errors as a way of promoting relational closeness to her fans, and the surprising psychological impacts of celebrity gossip columns and the role of in groups and outgroups. So all of that and more after this short break. 2%. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available.
去泡杯茶，然后我们再来讨论泰勒·斯威夫特的营销力量、她的“时代（Eras）”如何拉近她与粉丝之间的关系，以及名人八卦专栏令人惊讶的心理影响，还有内群体和外q群体的作用。所有这些以及更多内容，都在这段简短的广告之后。2%。这是在有自动扶梯可用时，依然选择走楼梯的人的比例。
I'm Michael Easter, and on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness and building resilience in our strange modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more, to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry. We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong. Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the result of stress.
我是迈克尔·伊斯特（Michael Easter），在我的播客节目《2%》中，我将剖析我们这个奇怪的现代社会中关于心理坚韧、健身和培养抗挫力的科学。我将与作家、研究人员以及其他健康和健身专家等展开对话，带大家看穿主导健康产业的不切实际且过于复杂的伪科学。我们曾经真的以为种子油天生就会引发炎症。我们搞错了。我们在世界上感到恐慌的许多问题，其实都是压力的结果。
Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the outside. other side, a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's T-W-O-Persent on the I-Hart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. There's two golden rules that any man should live by. Rule one, never mess with a country girl. You play stupid games, you get stupid prizes. And rule two, never mess with her friends either.
经历一些艰难困苦，你就会浴火重生，成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的自己。收听《2%》。节目名称是 2% (T-W-O-Percent)，可在 iHeartRadio app、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听。任何男人都应该遵循两条黄金法则。法则一，千万别惹乡下女孩。你玩愚蠢的游戏，就会得到愚蠢的下场。法则二，也千万别惹她的朋友。
We always say that trust your girl. I'm Anna Sinfield, and in this new season of The Girlfriends, Oh my God, this is the same man. A group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist. I felt like I got hit by a truck. I thought, how could this happen to me? The cops didn't seem to care, so they take matters into their own hands. I said, oh, hell no.
我们总是说要相信你的女孩。我是安娜·辛菲尔德（Anna Sinfield），在《女朋友们》（The Girlfriends）的新季度中，天哪，这是同一个男人。一群女性发现她们都与同一个多产的骗子约会过。我感觉自己像被卡车撞了。我想，怎么会发生这种事？警察似乎并不在意，于是她们决定自己采取行动。我说，哦，见鬼去吧。
I vowed, I will be his last target. He's going to get what he deserves. Listen to the Girlfriends. Trust me, babe. on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Do you remember when Diana Ross double-tapped Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs? Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people. I know what you're thinking.
我发誓，我一定要做他最后一个目标。他会得到应有的惩罚。收听《女朋友们》。相信我，宝贝。可在 iHeartRadio app、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听。你还记得黛安娜·罗斯（Diana Ross）在 VMA 颁奖典礼上双击莉莉·金（Lil' Kim）的胸部吗？或者坎耶（Kanye）说乔治·布什不喜欢黑人时。我知道你在想什么。
What the hell does George Bush got to do with Little Kim? Well, you can find out on the Look Back at it podcast. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill, waxing all. all about crack in the 80s. To be clear, 84 is big to me, not just because of crack.
乔治·布什跟莉莉·金到底有什么关系？好吧，你可以在《Look Back at It》播客中找到答案。我是萨姆·J（Sam J.）。我是亚历克斯·英格利士（Alex English）。每集节目中，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生了什么，并试图理解我们是如何熬过来的。其中包括最近一集邀请了马克·拉蒙特·希尔（Mark Lamont Hill），畅谈80年代的快克可卡因。需要说明的是，84年对我来说意义重大，不仅仅是因为快克。
I'm down to talk about crack all day, but just so you all know. I mean, at this point, Mark, this is the second episode where we've discussed crack. So I'm starting to see that there's a through line. We also have AIDS on the table right now. Thank you finishing that sentence. Yes. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Really?
我可以一整天都在聊快克，但为了让大家明白我的意思。我是说，马克，这已经是我们讨论快克的第二集了。所以我开始看出这里面有一条贯穿始终的线索。我们现在还把艾滋病摆在台面上。谢谢你把话说完。是的。我不认为对黑人来说还有比这更重要的年份了。真的吗？
Yeah. For me, it's one of the most important years for black people in American history. Listen to look back at it on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hardway with me, your host, and your favorite therapist, Keer Games. And in recognition of mental health awareness month, I'm bringing over a decade of my own experience in the mental health field and conversations with so many incredible guests. I'm talking, Tripp Fontaine, Ryan Clark. Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing, we get so wrapped up in the chase that we don't realize that we,
是的。对我来说，这是美国历史上对黑人而言最重要的年份之一。在 iHeartRadio app、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Look Back at It》。欢迎收听我的新播客《Learn the Hardway》，我是主持人、你最喜欢的治疗师基尔·盖恩斯（Keer Games）。为了致敬心理健康意识月，我将把我在心理健康领域十多年的经验以及与众多不可思议的嘉宾的对话带给大家。我说的是特里普·方丹（Tripp Fontaine）、瑞安·克拉克（Ryan Clark）。有时，当我们追求某样东西时，我们太过于沉迷于追逐的过程，以至于没有意识到我们
are in possession of the thing. And we're still chasing it. And we don't know when we've done enough. Because people scoreboard watch. Life becomes about wins and losses. Steve Burns, Dustin Ross, because you find it important to be a good person while you hear on earth?
已经拥有了那个东西。而我们还在继续追逐。我们不知道什么时候才算足够。因为人们总是在看记分牌。生活变成了关于输赢的较量。史蒂夫·伯恩斯（Steve Burns）、达斯、罗斯，因为你觉得在这个世界上活着做一个好人很重要？
Or are you a good person because you're afraid? Because that's two different intentions, bro. Absolutely. And that's two different levels of trust. I want you to just really be a good person. Join me, Kear Gaines, is we have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood, pressure,
还是说，因为你心存畏惧，所以才装作好人？因为这是两种完全不同的动机，兄弟。确实如此。这也是两种不同层次的信任。我希望你能真正发自内心地做一个好人。我是主持人科尔·盖恩斯（Kear Gaines），欢迎收听我的全新播客《Learn the Hardway》，在这里我们将深入探讨治愈、成长、父爱、压力以及人生目标。打开免费的 iHeartRadio 应用，搜索“Learn the Hardway”并立即收听。因此，如果你熟悉泰勒·斯威夫特（Taylor Swift），你就会知道，她的品牌以及她发行音乐的方式中有一个极其巨大的核心元素，那就是围绕着这些所谓的“时代”（eras）的创造展开的。
and purpose on my new podcast, Learn the Hardway. Open your free iHeartRadio app, search Learn the Hardway and listen now. So if you are familiar with Taylor Swift, you will know that a massive element of her brand and the way she releases music is centered on the creation of these so-called errors.
从本质上讲，泰勒通过她发行的每一张新专辑，都在塑造和展现一个略有不同的自己。在过去的十年里，她的职业生涯越来越频繁地做到了这一点，从一个有时带有相当浓厚乡村音乐色彩和小镇情怀的乡村艺术家，
Essentially, with every new album that she releases, Taylor portrays and reveals this, slightly different version of herself. And she's done this increasingly in the past 10 years of her career going from a small town country artist with at times quite
带着基督教色彩和理想，转变为凭借《1989》惊艳全场的流行偶像，再到通过《Reputation》涉足摇滚与流行乐，凭借《Folklore》和《Evermore》转向民谣与独立音乐，最后又通过诸如《Midnights》这样一张张专辑，回归到那种强烈的流行叙事风格中。
Christian undertones and ideals to a pop idol with 1989, moving into rock and pot with reputation, folk and indie music with folklore and evermore and then returning to that very pop narrative focus with albums
不同的不仅是音乐，这一点至关重要。还有她用来代表这个新篇章的色彩，她居住的城市，以及各种主题装置。例如，在《Lover》时期，一切都围绕着一个非常浪漫的前提展开：爱心、亮片、薄纱、婚姻、永远以及粉蓝色的天空。而在《Reputation》时期，则是皮衣、蛇、摩托车、黑暗且近乎 emo 的妆容理念，以及关于因果报应和复仇的想法。甚至她的“时代”也在不断演变，并体现在她如何展现自己、穿什么衣服、如何与粉丝群体互动上，这一切都取决于她当时身处哪个时代，你知道的，她和谁交往，她的一切
like Midnights. It's not just the music that is different and that is important. It is the colors that she uses to represent this new chapter. It is the cities that she's living in. It is the thematic devices. For example, with lover, everything was centered on this very romantic premise. Love hearts and sequins and tulle and marriage and forever and pastel blue skies with reputation. It was leather and snakes and motorcycles and dark almost emo makeup ideas of karma and revenge and her errors even evolve and represent in how she presents herself what she wears how she's engaging with her fan base based on the era that she is in you know who she's associated with everything about her
都会根据她所处的位置、发行的专辑以及她人生的这一阶段而发生某种转变。作为一名艺术家，泰勒·斯威夫特将不断演变、尝试新流派和新角色作为其商业模式的一部分。从心理学的角度来看，这种做法的重要意义绝对不容忽视，因为我认为，除了她的亲和力之外，这是她所拥有的最伟大的营销资产之一。你甚至不需要看太远就能发现这一点，你知道的，这就是她最近的巡演名称的由来。
kind of shifts based on where she's at the album she releases this chapter in her life As an artist, Taylor Swift has made it part of her business model to be constantly evolving, to be testing new genres, new personas. And the significance of this from a psychological perspective really cannot be overlooked because I think aside from her relatability, it is one of the greatest marketing assets that she has at her disposal. And you don't really need to look that far to see that. It's, you know, what her recent tour was named after.
这不仅极大地延长了她的艺术生命并成就了她的成功，而且也是“霉粉”（Swifty）文化中的一件大事：你从哪个时代开始听泰勒的歌，几乎就赋予了你某种社会地位。这里有一个非常关键的原因，解释了为什么这吸引了如此多的人，不仅吸引他们去听她的音乐，还让他们被她这个人所吸引。人类渴望新鲜感。我们渴望新奇。我们厌倦的速度相对较快，因为当我们没有受到挑战时，
it's not only a huge contributor to her longevity and success, but a massive thing in Swifty culture where the era that you started listening to Taylor almost in parts some kind of social status. And there's a really key reason why this attracts so many people, not just to her music, but to her as a person. Humans crave newness. We crave novelty. We get bored relatively quickly because when we are not being challenged,
或者没有受到刺激，我们的大脑就没有任何东西可以用来帮助你成长或拓展。它没有什么东西可以刺激它，所以它会去寻找别的东西。研究表明，新鲜感会触发大脑奖赏中心释放多巴胺。它能维持我们的注意力，让我们保持好奇心。而对于像泰勒这样的大牌音乐人来说，这能让我们持续投入。如果泰勒·斯威夫特只是继续制作乡村专辑，因为她认为那是她的粉丝对她唯一的期望，我真的很怀疑她能取得今天的这种成功，她能卖出今天这样的演唱会门票，但她承担了风险，并允许自己不断发展，满足粉丝不仅对更多的泰勒和更多的音乐的需求，还有对新泰勒的需求
or stimulated, our brain has nothing to take to you grow or expand. It has nothing to kind of stimulate it. So it will look for something else. And studies have shown that novelty triggers the release of dopamine in the reward centers of the brain. It keeps our attention sustained. It keeps us curious. And when it comes to massive musicians like Taylor, it keeps us invested. If Taylor Swift had just kept making country albums because she thought that was the only thing that her fans wanted from her. I really doubt that she would be the kind of success that she is now, that she would be selling the kind of concert tickets that she is now, but she took risks and she allowed herself to develop meeting the demand from her fans not only for just more Taylor and more music, but new Taylor
以及不同的音乐，一些能够持续吸引我们注意力的东西。同样值得注意的是，这种适应能力、这种成长、这种不断的改变，并不是人们对男艺术家们的期望。人们允许男艺术家们找到他们的细分领域并在那里度过他们的整个职业生涯。你知道的，他们不需要对粉丝的要求那么敏感。他们当然不需要像碧昂丝或Lady Gaga这样我们最喜欢的某些女明星那样，去展现那种令人眼花缭乱的演出、戏剧效果、服装和人设。我认为有时这给泰勒带来了个人的伤害，正如她在Netflix纪录片《美国小姐与心碎王子》中所谈到的那样。
and different music, something that's going to keep. keep our attention. It's also worth noting that this adaptability, this growth, this constant changing is not something that is expected from male artists. They are allowed to find their niche and stay there for their entire careers. They know, you know, they do not have to be as sensitive to the demands of their fans. They most certainly do not have to put on the kind of shows and theatrics and outfits and personas that are expected from some of our favorite female stars like Beyonce or Lady Gaga. And I think that at times has come at a personal detriment to Taylor, as she spoke about in her documentary, Miss Americana and The Heartbreak Prince on Netflix.
正如她所说，女艺术家们必须一次又一次地不断重塑自我，否则就会失业。许多女音乐人并没有男性同行那样长的职业生涯。很多时候，当她们年满30岁，不再年轻貌美、不再是那个闪闪发光的新鲜事物时，她们就会被某种程度上抛弃。因此，她们需要对我们保持新鲜感，需要在我们面前保持年轻，但这种年轻只能以我们想要的方式存在，甚至在我们自己都没有意识到的时候。她们需要为了粉丝、为了观众来重塑自我，
As she says, female artists have to constantly reinvent themselves so many times or they're out of a job. So many female musicians do not have the career longevity that is afforded to their male colleagues. A lot of the time they are kind of discarded by the time they turn 30, when they're not pretty, when they're not the shiny new thing. And so they need to be new to us, they need to be young to us, but only in the way that we want without even knowing it. They need to reinvent themselves for the fans, for the audience. in a way that is both very comforting but also a challenge,
以一种既让人感到非常安心，同时又充满挑战的方式，真正活出不断演变以娱乐我们的叙事。因此，虽然我认为这是一个对她的职业生涯极其有利的策略，而且也是她随着年龄增长和个人发展而产生的自然演变，但这同时也表明，人类对新鲜感和持续娱乐的渴望，给这些我们熟知并热爱的音乐人带来了哪些意想不到的后果。现在，关于泰勒·斯威夫工作为名人、作为一个人设以及她的品牌，还有另外两个方面，我认为我们需要谈谈，而我们到目前为止还没有真正触及。我当时不确定这是否需要被包含进来，但我认为
and really live out a narrative of constantly evolving to entertain us. So whilst this is a strategy that I think has been incredibly beneficial to her career, and also I think just a natural evolution as she's aged and developed as a person, it also goes to show how the human desire for novelty and constant entertainment has these unexpected consequences for the musicians that will. we know and love. Now, there are two more aspects to Taylor Swift's identity as a celebrity, as a persona, and her kind of brand that I think we need to talk about that we haven't really touched on so far. And I was unsure as to whether this needed to be included, but I think
她品牌和人设背后这些面貌或元素的心理学，实在是太迷人了，不容在这次对话中漏掉。所以首先是名人八卦的作用，以及我们对她的感情生活看似普遍的痴迷。其次是“霉粉”粉丝群体的力量，尤其是死忠粉能教给我们关于内群体和外群体思维的知识。作为一个名人，你的私生活是每个人都觉得自己有权涉足的领域，这并不是什么秘密。尽管这种想法可能是错位的，但你不再是一个个体，而是一种商品、一个供人消费的角色、一个真正用来让大众保持娱乐的东西，而泰勒·斯威夫特从16岁左右开始就一直在做这件事，无论是哈里·斯泰尔斯（Harry Styles）、汤姆·希德勒斯顿（Tom Hiddleston）还是
the psychology behind these facets or elements to her brand and persona is really too fascinating to leave out of this conversation. So firstly is the role of celebrity gossip and our seemingly universal obsession with her dating life. And secondly, the power of the Swifty fandom, especially what the die-hard fans can teach us about in-group and out-group thinking. It's no secret that as a famous person, your private life is something that everyone feels like they have access to. As misguided as that may be, you are no longer an individual but a commodity, a character to be consumed, something to really keep the masses entertained, and Taylor Swift has been doing just that, probably ever since she was 16, whether it was Harry Stiles or Tom Hiddleston or
乔·阿尔文（Joe Alwyn），无论他是谁，我们对她和谁在一起都有一种真正痴迷的狂热。很明显，她词曲创作的自传性质意味着她某种程度上招致了这种关注，但她也在履行自己作为词曲作家的职责。她会从自己的生活中取材。而且我认为她用《Folklore》和《Evermore》真正证明了，即使不需要引用她自己的生活，她依然是一位无可挑剔的音乐人。实际上，我觉得围绕着泰勒·斯威夫特的整个八卦叙事这个概念真的非常有趣，因为特别是在她20出头的时候，
Joe Alwyn, whoever it may be, we have this really obsessive fascination with who she is with. And obviously the autobiographical nature of her songwriting means that she invites that somewhat, but she's also doing her job as a songwriter. She will take things from her own life. And I think she really proved with folklore and evermore that she is still an impeccable musician without needing to reference her own life. It's actually really interesting, I think, this whole idea of the gossip narrative around Taylor Swift, because especially in her early 20s,
她有点像是老式荡妇羞辱的避雷针。你知道的，当时流传不息的说法是她一直在追求并抛弃男人，说她是个“噬男魔”。有人评论说，她和哪个男人被拍到在一起，就会为他写一首歌。而在过去的几年里，感觉媒体终于开窍了，意识到人们不再那么容忍这种言论了，这种叙事方式——尤其是在我大约14、15岁的时候，你随手拿起一本小报，里面总会有关于她恋情的一些阴谋论。有一段时间，这种情况有所消退。但有趣的是，几天前我在机场。当时我正在买登机前的零食，然后我看向杂志专区，上面赫然印着泰勒和特拉维斯·凯尔西（Travis Kelce）的整页封面，顺便说一句，
she was kind of like a lightning rod for good old-fashioned slut shaming. You know, the constant narrative was that she was picking up and disposing men that she was a man-eater. There were comments that she would write a song about any guy she was seen with. And then in the past few years, it feels like the media has kind of clued in that people don't tolerate that as much, that kind of narrative, especially when I was maybe 14 or 15, you could not pick up a tabloid without seeing some theory about her relationships. And for a while, that died down. But it's interesting because a few days ago, I was at the airport. I was buying my pre-flight snacks. And I look over to the magazine section, and there is Taylor and a full page cover on her and Travis Kelsey, who, by the way,
我是澳大利亚人，而且我也不喜欢体育，但我前几天真的看了一场 NFL 比赛。由于特拉维斯·凯尔西与泰勒·斯威夫特的恋情，我的 Instagram 上全都是他的 NFL 视频。这充分展示了那种影响力。还有，收视率上升了，出勤率也上升了，泰勒·斯威夫特似乎点石成金。那么，人们为什么对她的感情生活如此着迷呢？为什么我们这么喜欢名人八卦？尤其是当这些八卦涉及他们生活中某些深度脆弱和私密的方面时？我想我们可以给出几种解释。
I'm Australian and also I don't like sports, but I genuinely watch an NFL game the other day. I am getting like NFL videos on my Instagram of Travis Kelsey because of his association with Taylor Swift. That goes to show that power. Also like viewership was up, attendance was up, Taylor Swift kind of touches something and it turns to gold. So what is the obsession particularly with her love life? Why do we love celebrity gossip so much? especially when it's about certain deeply vulnerable and personal aspects of their lives. I think we can offer up a few explanations.
首先，在心理学中，在社会心理学中，有一种理论认为，八卦是一种沟通或社交的方式，它真正能让我们产生一种“知情”的感觉。因此，我们在与他人交流时有更多的话题。这有点像社交润滑剂，如果找不到更好的词来形容的话。它充当了一种社会黏合剂的形式，通过共享的知识和经历将我们绑定在一起，特别是当涉及到像泰勒·斯威夫特以及其他名人这样知名的人物时。其次，消费这种内容会让你在某种程度上感觉自己与你的偶像或你最喜欢的艺术家联系得更紧密。
Firstly, in psychology, in social psychology, the theory is that gossip is a way of communicating or socializing that really allows us to feel in the know. And therefore, we have more to talk about with others. It's kind of like a social lubricant, for lack of a better word. it serves as a form of social glue binding us together through shared knowledge and experiences, particularly when it comes to well-known figures like Taylor Swift, like other celebrities. Secondly, consuming this kind of content makes you feel more connected with your idol or your favorite artist kind of by proxy.
通过阅读关于她在和谁约会、在哪里用餐、穿着什么、她的房子长什么样的文章，让我们觉得我们与这个人之间产生了某种联系，从而进一步巩固了我们对他们的兴趣和投入。这就是一位心理学家所说的与某人成为“法律上的朋友”的感觉，但它也可以作为一种缓解压力的方式，因为我们可以专注于别人生活中的考验、审判和细节，将其作为一种逃避现实的方式，而不是去关注我们自己的生活。所以它在某种程度上麻木了我们的无聊感，甚至可能还有不快乐感。我认为，当我们看到或者有时决定在网上对名人发表负面评论或充满仇恨的言论、观点时，情况尤其如此。十有八九，
by consuming articles about who she's dating, where she's dining, what she's wearing, what her house looks like, it makes us feel like we have a connection with this person, further really entrenching our interests and our investment in them. It's what one psychologist has called the feeling of being friends in law with someone, but it can also serve as a form of stress relief as well because we are able to focus on the trials, tribunal. details of someone else's lives like a form of escapism rather than our own. So it kind of numbs our feelings of boredom or even maybe unhappiness. And I think that's especially true when we see or sometimes decide to write negative comments or hateful things, opinions online about famous people. nine out of ten times, that is a projection of our own insecurities or sense of inadequacy. And due to this person's status, as a celebrity, we feel as if, A, what we say is harmless,
这都是我们自身的不安全感或无能感的投射。由于这个人作为名人的地位，我们会觉得，A，我们说的话是无害的，
and B, we have some sense of anonymity. And so the shame attached to what would typically be quite an anti-social practice is diminished compared to if we were doing it about someone that we actually know. celebrity gossip is both a distraction and an outlet. Finally, I want to move away from talking about Taylor Swift and briefly talk about her fan base. So the psychology behind the Swifty fan base, of which I'm definitely a part of, could honestly be its own episode, but a concept I think is really important to cover here
B，我们有一种匿名感。因此，与通常被认为相当反社会的行为相关的羞耻感，比起我们对实际认识的人这样做时要少得多。名人八卦既是一种分散注意力的手段，也是一种宣泄的出口。最后，我想把话题从泰勒·斯威夫特身上移开，简要谈谈她的粉丝群体。因此，“霉粉”粉丝群体背后的心理学——我绝对是其中一员——老实说完全可以单独做成一期节目，但我认为这里有一个非常概念需要涵盖，
is the role of in-group and out-group interactions, especially as it relates to. to kind of the desire of fans to defend Taylor Swift against all possible insult and their extreme loyalty. Loyalty like that is not easy to cultivate, especially between yourself and people that you've never met. And yet Taylor Swift is, when she's criticized by the media, when nasty articles are written about her or tweets or an ex-boyfriend like Jake Gyllen Hall or Calvin Harris is perceived as treating her badly, there are thousands of fans who will go to battle for Taylor. And we can explain this using the theory of social categorization. So when it comes to her as an artist as a celebrity, there is an in-group, people who love her
那就是内群体和外群体互动的作用，尤其是当它与粉丝渴望保护泰勒·斯威夫特免受所有可能的侮辱以及他们极端的忠诚度相关时。这样的忠诚度并不容易培养，特别是当你和从未谋面的人之间。然而泰勒·斯威夫特——当她受到媒体批评时，当关于她的恶毒文章或推文被写出来时，或者当人们觉得她的前男友杰克·吉伦哈尔（Jake Gyllenhaal）或卡尔文·哈里斯（Calvin Harris）对她不好的时候——有成千上万的粉丝会为泰勒挺身而出。我们可以用社会分类理论来解释这一点。因此，当谈到她作为一个艺术家、一个名人时，存在着一个内群体，即那些热爱她
music and support her, and an out-group. People who don't enjoy her music or who criticize her or reduce her songwriting, basically people who are not fans. So based on what we know about social psychology, in groups and outgroups are very naturally opposed. There is a sense of them and a sense of us. And those who are members of the in-group, they feel a really intense sense of loyalty to one another or to a certain person because they psychologically identify with a set of certain character traits, likes, interests, obsessions characteristic that others in the group also share. And the main thing binding Swifty's together is their love for Taylor. We feel aligned and similar to her, but also to each other
音乐并支持她的人，还有一个外群体。也就是那些不喜欢她的音乐、批评她或贬低她的词曲创作的人，基本上就是那些不是粉丝的人。因此，根据我们对社会心理学的了解，内群体和外群体是自然对立的。有一种“他们”的感觉，也有有一种“我们”的感觉。那些内群体的成员，他们对彼此或对某特定的人会产生一种极其强烈的忠诚感，因为他们在心理上认同一系列特定的性格特征、喜好、兴趣以及该群体中其他人也共同具有的特征。将“霉粉”紧密团结在一起的主要核心是对泰勒的爱。我们觉得与她志趣相投、十分相似，同时也与彼此相似，
because, you know, not just because of music preferences, but also certain beliefs and familiarity. There is a strong emotional and social bond that people feel with her but also with other fans of her music. And in general, when people become real superfans or part of a fandom, it's often because there's something about that person that does connect back to their identity in some way. And so when we observe or talk to people who fall into the outgroup of people who don't like Taylor Swift, we see them as very different or perhaps as possessing some kind of negative perception or misunderstanding, they just don't get how amazing her music is. They just don't understand how powerful her presence is, everything that we love about her.
因为，你知道的，不仅仅是因为音乐偏好，还因为某些信仰和熟悉感。人们对她以及对她音乐的其他粉丝产生了一种强烈的、情感上的和社会性的纽带。总的来说，当人们成为真正的超级粉丝或某个粉丝群体的一部分时，通常是因为那个人的某些特质在某种程度上确实与他们自己的身份产生了共鸣。因此，当我们观察那些落入不喜欢泰勒·斯威夫特的外群体的人，或者与他们交谈时，我们认为他们非常不同，或者可能带有某种负面的看法或误解，他们只是不明白她的音乐有多么惊艳。他们只是不理解她那强大的存在感，以及我们所热爱关于她的这一切。
And so when they challenge Taylor Swift's artistry and her work, they directly challenge our core beliefs and our adoration of her. So it feels like a personal threat. It feels like a personal insult and people really react. accordingly. And that's why we sometimes see such intense emotional behavioral reactions. I think at the end of the day, Taylor Swift has been able to do something that few other musicians, bands, performers have ever done. She has maintained an incredible longevity as an artist. And as someone who is continuously gaining new listeners who has this sense of notoriety that so
因此，当他们挑战泰勒·斯威夫特的艺术造诣和作品时，他们就直接挑战了我们的核心信仰以及我们对她的崇拜。所以这感觉像是一种人身威胁。这感觉像是一种人身侮辱，人们自然会做出相应的反应。这就是为什么我们有时会看到如此强烈的情感和行为反应。我认为归根结底，泰勒·斯威夫特做到了一件很少有其他音乐人、乐队、表演者曾经做到过的事情。作为一名艺术家，她保持了令人难以置信的长久生命力。作为一个不断获得新听众、并拥有这种声誉的人，
many people would want that so many people crave. And to summarize, it really comes down to four major factors. Firstly, relatability. She writes songs that we can connect to. Secondly, familiarity. A lot of us have grown up alongside her. So her music feels like it is something that has accompanied the major moments in our life. She doesn't just feel like a famous person. She feels like a friend. Thirdly is aspiration. She is a role model and someone that we can aspire to, someone that we want to be like, whose behavior we want to replicate. And, you know, take for example, her re-recording her old music, that is a freaking power play. That is amazing. Claiming over, you know, ownership over her work. That is a huge move. Whatever you think about Taylor Swift,
这是很多人梦寐以求、渴望得到的。总而言之，这 realmente 归结为四个主要因素。首先，共鸣感。她创作的歌曲能够让我们产生共鸣。其次，熟悉感。我们很多人都是伴随着她一起成长的。因此，她的音乐感觉就像是陪伴了我们人生中重要时刻的东西。她不只是感觉像一个名人。她感觉更像是一个朋友。第三点是激励性。她是一个榜样，是我们向往的人，是我们想要成为的人，是那个我们想要效仿其行为的人。而且，你知道的，以她重新录制自己的旧音乐为例，这绝对是一个王牌操作。这太棒了。重新夺回对其作品的所有权。这是一个巨大的举动。无论你怎么看待泰勒·斯威夫特，
whether you like her or not, you really have to give her credit there. That's pretty, Amazing. And finally, as we discussed, she provides novelty and newness to her fans. She is continuously evolving, pushing herself, growing alongside her audience as they mature. And also, she gives them new stuff, exciting things, and that is so addictive. It's why she is so massive. And whether you are a huge fan, like myself, whether you are a Swifty or not, I think of a lot of the psychology we've explored goes to show exactly why she is a unique combination of both certain traits, characteristics, and also business decisions that have made her so widely successful. I don't think all of it was strategic, but she really captures
不管你是否喜欢她，你真的不得不佩服她。这真是太了不起了。最后，正如我们所讨论的，她为她的粉丝提供了新奇感和新鲜感。她不断演变、突破自我，随着观众的成熟与他们共同成长。同时，她给他们带来新的东西、令人兴奋的东西，而这太让人上瘾了。这也是她如此受欢迎的原因。无论你是一个像我一样的超级粉丝，不管你是不是“霉粉”，我认为我们所探索的很多心理学都恰恰表明了为什么她具备了一系列特定特质、特征以及商业决策的独特结合，从而让她取得了如此广泛的成功。我不认为这一切都是出于策略，但她确实捕捉到了
something about the human spirit and our need for escapism and relatability and storytelling. And I think that is so powerful. So I really hope that you have enjoyed this episode. to be honest, I think I was the person most excited for this. I fucking love Taylor Swift. I just made a whole episode on her. She is amazing. And it was actually so revealing to understand why that obsession is, why I am so addicted to knowing more about her to listening to her music. It's like such a combination of so many insane different interactions and psychological theories and concepts. So I hope that you got something out of this that you enjoyed this episode. As always, if there is someone you know out there who would like this episode who would get a kick out of it, please feel free to share it with a friend,
人类精神中关于我们对逃避现实、共鸣感和讲故事的需求的某些特质，我认为这非常有力量。所以我真的很希望你们能喜欢这一期节目。老实说，我觉得我自己才是对这期节目最兴奋的人。我他妈太爱泰勒·斯威夫特了。我刚刚为她做了一整期节目。她太棒了。而且能够理解这种痴迷的原因，为什么我对了解更多关于她的事情、听她的音乐如此上瘾，其实是一件非常启发心智的事情。这就像是这么多疯狂的、不同的互动以及心理学理论和概念的结合。所以希望你能从中获得一些收获，并且喜欢这一期节目。像往常一样，如果你身边有谁会喜欢这期节目、会从中得到乐趣的话，请随时分享给朋友，
a family member, a colleague, whoever it may be. Make sure that you are following us on Instagram at That Psychology Podcast. I'm at Gemma Speg if you want to see some more behind the scenes content. Thank you so much for listening to today's episode and we will be back next week with another one. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person.
家人、同事，无论他是谁。确保在 Instagram 上关注我们，账号是 That Psychology Podcast。如果你想看更多幕后花絮内容，我的账号是 Gemma Speg。非常感谢大家收听今天的节目，我们下周将带着另一期节目回归。2%。这是当有自动扶梯可用时，仍然选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特（Michael Easter）。在我的播客《2%》中，我将剖析心理韧性、健身以及在我们这个奇特的现代世界中建立复原力的科学。经历一些艰难险阻，你就会以一个更快乐、更有成就感、更健康的姿态从另一端走出来。
Listen to 2%. That's TWO% on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On The Look Back at it podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year,
收听《2%》。即 TWO%，可在 IHeart Radio 应用、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听。在《Look Back at it》播客中。从1979年开始，那对我和我来说是一个重要的时刻。84年对我很重要。我是萨姆·J（Sam J）。我是亚历克斯·英格利什（Alex English）。在每一期节目中，我们都会挑选一个年份，
unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it, with our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Listen to Look Back at it on the IHeart Radio app,
剖析当时发生了什么，并试图弄清楚我们是如何与我们的朋友、同为喜剧演员的同行以及最喜爱的作家一起在其中生存下来的。比如马克·拉蒙特·希尔（Mark Lamont Hill）聊80年代。84年是一个疯狂的年份。那真是个疯狂的年份。我认为对于黑人来说，没有比这更重要的年份了。在 IHeart Radio 应用上收听《Look Back at it》，
Apple Podcast. or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hard Way with your favorite therapist and host, Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional
Apple Podcast，或在任何你获取播客的地方收听。嘿，大家过得怎么样？你们正在收听由你们最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人科尔·盖恩斯（Kear Games）主持的《Learn the Hardway》。这个空间探讨黑人男性的经历，进行那些在其他地方绝对无法安全展开的坦诚对话，而你是在与一位知道自己在做什么的持证专业人士交流
who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor? It signals to the world that you're not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to. Listen to learn the hard way on the AHA radio Apple Podcast or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins, but the pregnancy
有多少男人穿着一身盔甲？这向世界发出信号，表明你是不好惹的。仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着你就必须使用它。在 AHA 广播、Apple Podcast 或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Learn the Hardway》。在2023年，《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德（Clayton Echard）被指控孕育了双胞胎，但这次怀孕
appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice in so much, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg Gillespie and Michael Ranchini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young.
似乎是一场骗局。这个特定的测试你前后篡改了两次，对吧？我篡改过测试一次。这惊动了一大批网络侦探，才揭露出一个令人不安的模式。另外两名经历过同样事情的男子，格雷g·吉莱斯皮和迈克尔·兰奇尼。我简直震惊了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。
This is love trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. This is an IHeart podcast. Guaranteed human. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
这里是“困在爱中”。我是斯科茨代尔警局的劳拉。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于受到了惩罚。请在iHeart Radio应用、苹果播客或您获取播客的任何地方收听“困在爱中”播客。这是一个iHeart播客。保证由真人制作。本集暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。